Let's take a look at a commonly used kernel in scientific computation.
This is called N-body computation. In an N-body computation you have N objects,
each of which exerts a force on each other object.
You'll use N-body computations to, say, model the gravitational interaction between stars and a galaxy
or the electrostatic forces between a number of charged particles.
It's the way we compute molecular dynamics, which in turn can model protein folding and misfolding
and is an important component of our understanding of disease and drug discovery.
N-body techniques are used in folding at home, for instance.
The specific formulation of N-body computation that we'll discuss today is called all-pairs N-body,
and I'm basing this discussion on an excellent article by Lars Nyland, Mark Harris, and Jan Prins in 2007 in GPU Gems 3.
All-pairs N-Body is the simplest N-body computation.
It's known as a brute-force method, and it involves separately calculating the force between each pair of elements
and then adding up the resulting forces on each element.
A simulation using N-body will usually have two steps.
First, compute the forces on each element, then move each element a little bit based on its force, and then repeat.
So we first want to understand the complexity of this approach.
So we have N objects, each of which computes the forces on it from each other object.
For N objects, what is the work complexity of computing all-pairs N-body?
Is the amount of work proportional to N, N log N, N squared, or N cubed?